Now, typically with FK setups, as I was saying, you want the control's initial start point
to be in the same place as the bone that you're trying to control.
So what we can do here is we could select the other elbow, for example.
We can right-click that bone, come up to New, and create a new control in the same way that
we did before, except this time, that will automatically position and orient the control
to match that of the bone that you had selected.
Something that it also does is names the control the same as your bone and adds underscore CTRL
at the end.
And this is just a great way of keeping your controls and your bone names separate so that
when you're using your rigging logic, things are a bit more straightforward.
In previous versions of the engine, this control would have been created as a child of the
bone that we had selected, and we'd recommend that you select the control and press Shift
P to remove it from the hierarchy, because it's best practice for the rig controls to
be in their own hierarchy rather than a skeleton's hierarchy.
And we can do the same thing with this.
We could change the shape, so we could go for another circle, and we could reposition the
shapes transformed the same way again.
So if we went 90 degrees on the Y axis, and increase the scale to 2, just so it's a little
easier to select.
So it's really as easy as that to start creating your controls.
Now what we'll start to do is build the logic for our FK controls.
So we'll create a root control that will be at the head of the hierarchy, and then we'll
create a control for the spine and set up a simple hierarchy for our rig.
So if I delete these two controls here, what I'll do is come up to the top, select our
root and our spine, and if I right click the two of these together, come up to New Control,
what that will do is create the two controls for us and put them down out of the hierarchy
down here.
Now to child the spine underneath the root control so that when we move the root control,
the spine comes with it, what we'll do is drag the spine control on top of the root
control, and you can see this child's under the root control, and you can see that based
on the small arrow that we have here, and the line connected to it.
Now if we change the look of our controls like we did before, with the root control,
we can create something like an octagon, and maybe it'll be yellow, and we'll scale it
up to something like 10.
Oh, we didn't keep that, so let's try that again.
There we go.
And with our spine control, this is stuck inside of our mesh at the moment, so what
I'm going to do first is just scale it up until we can see it a little better, something
like 3.5, and then we'll change the shape again to be a circle, and we can see again
that it's slightly misoriented for how we'd like to use it.
So using the shape transform, what I'm going to do is rotate 90 degrees on Y again, and
I'll even scale it up a little more, maybe 4 will be better.
So as you can see, we have our two controls here now, and as I move the root control around,
our spine control follows.
Now let's set up the logic to connect our controls and our bones together.
So what we'll do first is we will grab our control here, click and hold and drag it into
the rig graph, and we'll choose get control.
So this is going to get the transforming information about this control, and because we want the
root control to control our root bone, I'll also grab the root bone and drag that in,
and I'll choose set root bone, because we want to use the transforms of the control to set
the transforms of the bone.
And to connect these two together, we grab the transform output pin and plug that into
the value input pin of the set transform bone node, and then we just connect the logic up.
I compile that and select our control.
What we'll see is our control is now controlling our skeleton.
Now if we set the same thing up with the spine control, currently that's doing nothing, that's
not affecting skeleton in any way, but if we drag that into the rig graph and choose
get control, and then we drag in our spine 01 bone and choose set bone, connect the transform
to the value pin, connect up the execute logic, and when we hit compile, we'll see that this
control is now controlling our spine.
It really is that straightforward to get your controls driving your bones and moving
your character, and now you could do this for all of the bones on your character, and
pretty quickly you'd have an FK rig that you could use to animate with.
But what if you wanted to get a bit more complex?
Now it's very common for characters with arms and feet to have an IK setup, which is a super
useful way of having the hands and feet drive the movement of the arms and legs, or even
pinning the hands and feet in place.
So let's do that next.
Let's create an IK setup for the arm.
So for this simple IK setup, we're going to use the basic IK node, and for this to work,
it needs a few different bits of information.
So if I right click inside our rig graph here, and search for basic IK, I can spell it right,
basic IK, this is the node that we're going to use.
Now we need to tell this which bones we want to affect, so we're going to set this up on
one of the arms.
We need to give it the effect information, which is essentially the wrist control or the
hand control that we're going to use to control the entire IK system.
And then we need to give it a pole vector, and this just allows us to control where the
elbow is going to point.
So first of all, let's create all the pieces that we're going to need to make this work.
So let's create our wrist control or hand control first.
So inside the rig hierarchy here, I'm just going to search for hand, and we'll set it
up on the right hand side.
So with hand are selected, I'm going to right click and create new control like we did before.
And I'm going to drag that inside our root control, so that wherever we move the root
control, all of the rest of the controls for the body will follow.
I'm also going to change the look of our wrist control or our hand control.
Let's come down here, make it a circle again.
If I just press F to zoom in, we can see that we need to rotate along the Y axis again.
And I'll do the same thing where I scale this up slightly.
Let's go to 1.5 maybe.
So compiling that, we now have our new control in the correct position where the hand is.
Our next control we need to make is a pole vector.
Now we need to make this at the position of the elbow because the elbow is what we're
going to be wanting to control.
So for us, that's our lower arm.
And make sure that we're choosing the right one here.
If I press control N, that's the shortcut to create a new control.
And then I'll do the same thing and bring that inside our root control.
And we can see that we are aligned with the elbow.
But I want to bring this out a little bit.
And I'm going to move this along the Y axis only because that's the axis of the bone that
we want to point towards the pole vector control, meaning we're maintaining the plane that the
bone is on.
So if I just bring it out to here somewhere that's nice and accessible, I'll then right
click and set our offset transform from current.
If I wasn't to do that and I was to compile our control rig, you see it snaps back to
where it originally spawned.
So if I pull that out again, right click, set offset transform from current.
Now when I compile, you see that that's this control's new initial location.
Now we have all the controls that we need.
Let's start setting up the basic IK.
So let's tell our basic IK node what bones we want to control.
Now this is going to be our upper arm bone, our lower arm bone, and our hand bone.
So in item A here, which will be the start of our chain, we want to put our upper arm
bone.
And we can just put that in by searching for the name of the bone.
Or what we could actually do is select the bone in the outliner here and the rikai raki
and use this arrow to use the name of what we have selected.
So if we choose our lower arm, if I search for it, lower arm R, I could just hit the
arrow there and then our hand R is going to be our effector or the end of our chain.
Now that we know what bones we're affecting, let's tell the system what controls we're
using.
So if I clear out our search there, come down to the bottom.
We have our hand control and our lower arm control.
I'm just going to right click and rename this to be our pole vector control.
So I'll put PVR control.
Now with both of these, I'll drag the two in and I'll choose get control so that we
can get the transforms and the information of these two controls.
Now we can see the hand control that I have here.
We're going to be using that as our effector control, which means it'll be directly driving
the effector at the end of the IK chain or our hand bone.
So if we connect the transforms directly up to the effector there, the last thing we
need to connect up is the pole vector control.
Now the pole vector is based on translation or position data only.
So if we open the transform tab here, grab our translation information from the pole
vector control and plug that into the pole vector pin here.
That's all we need to connect up to get the IK working.
So let's plug it into our execute chain here, connect the logic up.
And we can see that something's definitely changed, but it does look a little bit broken.
So it's sort of half working.
We've got an IK chain where we can move the hand around and the upper arm and the lower
arm respond to how that hand's moving.
It just seems to be that perhaps the rotation of the elbow here isn't quite right in relation
to the pole vector.
Now that's for two potential reasons.
It could be that our primary or secondary axis are slightly incorrect essentially.
I'm going to just disconnect this to get us back to our default pose.
And if I select our lower arm for our primary axis data, this is the axis that points along
the bone.
So if I zoom in here, you'll see that we have our local orientation axis that we can see
here of each bone.
Now if I just orient myself around here, you can see that this red line here indicates
that the x-axis is pointing down the bone or in the direction of the bone.
And it's actually the negative x-axis that is pointing down the direction of the bone
from the elbow to the wrist.
So under the primary axis here, although we are on the x-axis, we're currently set to
positive.
So I'm just going to flip that round to negative.
And if I correct our logic up or connect our logic up, we can see that this looks different
but we're still not quite correct.
So under our secondary axis here, if I disconnect the logic again and select the upper arm again
or the lower arm, sorry, we can see that this green line here indicates that the positive
y-axis is pointing towards our pole vector control.
So if I was to flip that to the positive one instead of negative one and connect to our
logic, we'll see that we now have a correctly working pole vector.
So it's quite important to make sure you orient your joints in the correct way so that you
know which axis is pointing down the bone and which axis will be your secondary axis
pointing towards things like your pole vector.
But now if we see if I just hide the bones, come up to character, bones, and just choose
selected only, which means any bone that we select would now be visible.
And if I select the wrist control here, we can see that it's now controlling our whole
arm and our pole vector control is controlling which direction the elbow is pointing.